all right a couple announcements before
I get started I want to set your
expectations a little bit low I'm just
getting over a cold I don't normally
sound like this sorry about that number
one number two I realized because this
is a Python audience you might think I'm
gonna talk about some interesting Python
projects at Cloudera like for example
you can now take the continuum Python
distribution and put it in CDH I'm not
going to talk about interesting Python
related things like that
in fact I figured since it's it's PI
data it's about Python and data and
maybe we shouldn't do both at once first
thing in the morning so in fact there's
gonna be almost no Python content in
this talk whatsoever I hope that's okay
lastly this is a talk about genomics and
I'm not a genomics expert either people
I work with are so I can I can tell you
the interesting things about things
we're doing with genomics at Cloudera
but please don't ask any clever
questions it probably won't know the
answer anyway so with all that all that
level setting accomplished let's get
into it
let's talk about genomics and I'm gonna
argue this is really a data problem at
heart genomics is well the study of our
genome and I hope you're thinking now
what's a genome well I know that's right
I think a lot of us studied this at some
point in in school or I've heard about
this but what is what is the genome and
what is the study of it well quite
simply organisms out there like us we
all have a genome because inside of us
we have cells I think you remember
you're with me so far I think and inside
the cell we have at some level a nucleus
with some genetic code in their DNA
right and if for humans if we looked at
our DNA we would find we have 23 pairs
of strands of genetic code and they're
encoded in with these base pairs a C G
and T they're like they're like strips
of data or code if you will and how
they're represented with a with amino
acids is is maybe not important for our
purposes what's important for us is what
they say or what they express what
what's a genetic information they they
encode and that's really our genome it's
the genetic information that these
this DNA in our cells and codes so this
is the success inside all of us instead
of all ourselves and it's it's amazing
when you think about it but without
losing much we can really think of our
genome where our genetic code is one big
long strip of genetic code of these base
pairs and it's billions of base pairs
long so it's a very long one-dimensional
string made out of four characters so
that's interesting but maybe what's
really surprising is how similar our
genomes are not just to each other but
even to other organisms it's actually
we're not that different from other
forms of life on the planet and so
certainly if you look at the genome from
different human beings you'll find
they're very similar like 99.99% similar
something like that and what that means
is because we're so similar we can begin
to talk about common areas of the genome
because they look so much alike we can
recognize features in one genome that
clearly correspond to features in
another that's interesting that's
powerful but if you take that a step
further it means that we should be able
to establish some kind of reference
genome if we're also similar we should
be able to find some median or a
meteoroid of all human genomes and call
that the reference human genome and
maybe that would be powerful or
interesting so you may remember and I
think about almost 20 years ago now this
announcement the completion of the human
genome projects
Bill Clinton sits up there with craig
Venter and announces that we've decoded
the book of life and this is really what
they were talking about they managed to
for the first time get a rough draft of
the reference human genome and took
about a decade and it cost about two
billion dollars but this is the first
time we had gotten some look at what we
thought was the genome for free humanity
and that was actually a big step forward
but because once we can talk about a
genome this common string of data that's
within all of us we can then the
find all of ourselves in terms of our
differences from that common genome so
it was cool that we could even do this
and sequence the whole genome but good
step forward for for sure but what that
gave us was only the beginning I think
what we get out of something like the
the the human genome project is
something like the equivalent of
satellite images so this is a satellite
image from Google Maps and even though I
used to live very close to where this is
I didn't recognize it because this isn't
really how we think about places on the
earth even though this is literally a
picture of a place on the earth I don't
know if anyone's gonna recognize what
this is even I didn't unless maybe we
start to label it this is someone guess
it's watching the square park okay Wow
very good
yes indeed this is Washington Square
Park in New York City so it's pretty
obvious once you turn on the labels in
Google Maps since its annotated right
it's well it's actually called
Washington Square Park there but even if
you didn't know that you know we sure we
never see eight streets and the West 4th
Street Station and so on and it's these
annotations that are really the useful
bit of the map I mean I'm guessing that
you and I don't really use the street
maps in satellite mode we used them in
this Maps mode we don't really literally
care about what's there we care about
what's logically there the station the
store this intersection this service and
so on so I think this this is by analogy
the next step we had to take in genomics
to make use of it we had to go from just
this raw map of the genome to some
logical representation of it what does
it mean what's there conceptually in the
genome not literally but logically so
that is we wanted to go from this
literally a look at the the base pairs
in the human genome to something like
this this is maybe a rough equivalent of
Google Maps for the human genome it's a
it's a browser and I and I appreciate
it's really hard to read even if you can
see
but what we've got here is it's like
here's the zoomed out view of the human
genome at the top it's about a couple
billions of base pairs long and that
little highlighted red region is the bit
we've expanded here below it's about six
hundred thousand base pairs wide this
bit we've expanded and we've zoomed in
on this and you can see annotations for
different sections of the genome so you
if you zoomed in further and further you
could see I assume at some level actual
base pairs but at this level we see more
interesting annotated features we
believe this section of the of the
genome codes this particular attributer
is related to this disease and so on and
it also interestingly has some other
funny comparisons with for example a
rhesus monkey a mouse and the dog
showing bits of our genome that we can
map to other animals genome as well
we're similar enough that we can even
draw those draw those analogies which is
which is kind of crazy
we're actually apparently a little bit
similar to two lampreys and some level
that that was shocking to me anyway so
this is where we want to go with
genomics we want to create more and more
of these labels we want to extract more
and more meaning from the genome by
understanding how people how their
genome varies and then mapping that to
observable attributes of people so that
we can understand logically what pieces
of the genome encode for humans and
understands better how we operate how
we're built so this is where I want to
connect it to a data problem because it
this is all very interesting but this is
mostly so far a bioinformatics problem
it sounds just like biology and and
genomics and so on what does this have
to do with data well I think actually
data and computing have been the key to
progress in this field it's not just
that better science better techniques
and so on have made it easier and more
effective to sequence the human genome
it's the technology is also
driven that driven that cost down as
well this is a chart of the cost to
sequence a single human genome that's on
a log scale note from 2001 to about this
year and it's dropped from about a
hundred million dollars down to about a
just over a thousand dollars which is
crazy here's the the Moore's Law trend
here and you can see that it's not just
advances in and Hardware getting faster
or maybe breakthroughs in the science
but there's also been some big
breakthroughs in applying technology to
this problem but I've led to these order
of magnitude drops in the cost and when
the cost goes down this much things can
qualitatively change it means we don't
just get more genome sequence for
cheaper we get better results we
understand more so so why is that why is
this such a data-driven problem well at
some level it's because the genetic code
is a big string and so it is inherently
uh something we can represent as data
and maybe manipulate this data but
there's a little more to it than that
I think you'll find that if you look at
how do you know these bioinformatics
processes work they're not just data
intensive but compute intensive so a lot
of the the process of sequencing a
genome involves chopping it up into
pieces getting a lot of little chunks of
DNA and then piecing them back together
as if we'd gotten to map and put it in a
blender
and then pasted it back onto a board
onto some kind of reference map of the
world so there's a lot of data moving
there but there's a lot of compute going
on as well and so the more we can apply
faster computing and smarter computing
and data processing to this problem the
faster it's going to get cheaper and
more effective and maybe the more we can
do with it as a result
so really bioinformatics has in the last
decade really been an informatics
problem it's a data science problem and
it's it's a data problem but we still
have a lot to do I think you won't be
surprised to learn that inside these
bioinformatics processes our pipelines
just I think everyone in the room
probably operates a data pipeline of
some
there's data land somewhere and
something is transforms it and something
else transforms it and then something
else is stored here and computed and put
there
pipelines are everywhere and certainly
that's true
in bioinformatics as well for example
one of the first steps is to take all
these all these reads and align them put
them onto a reference genome so the
details don't even matter that much here
but suffice to say these there's a bunch
of steps that have to happen to get from
raw DNA to understanding what's there in
the genome so people have built software
for this but maybe won't surprise you to
learn that it's been built by people
that aren't big data people it's been
built by researchers it's been built
there for ad hoc across many years
across many different research groups
that are maybe competing or maybe just
don't know each other exist but know
different languages that have different
ideas about what's important and so on
so I think the state of genomics
software technology such as it exists or
has existed maybe a couple years ago was
that your typical mess you had for this
pipeline you had a bunch of different
tools a lot of lot of times overlap
amongst tools different groups building
different tools for different for the
same activity
you had it seems more formats than even
intermediate stages somehow so everyone
defines their own file format to encode
the inputs and output to the different
stages making it really hard to even
share one to other plug one tool into
the other and of course everyone writes
in their own language sometimes people
write in Java
sometimes people were at the compute
intensive phases in some kind of
specialized HPC system sometimes the
native code sometimes all the above it's
just how it is but obviously we could do
better I mean after all it's not like
pipelines or anything new to the big
data world we everyday we manage flows
of information that consume one type of
data and output another type of
and it's not as if we can't imagine eyes
these things and make these things
standard and standardize on formats but
we just haven't done that yet not in
genomics so just to throw a couple more
stones this is an example of the VCF
file format
I've even forget what this thing codes
since I'm not an expert but I think you
can get a flavor for why the data
formats themselves might even be a
problem in this field or have been a
problem in the past so for example the
the file format such as it is is a I
think a gzip compressed file which isn't
splittable I mean you can't break up a
gzip file and process pieces of it
independently like you could a text file
or a v-sit file it looks the format
looks inspired a little bit by my
mainframe files you've got a header
section and then record so I call it
semi structured the header records
themselves have some structure that
differs from field to fields in some
cases this format is under specified so
it's not clear what you can and can't do
with the format in some cases it might
be over specified for example I think
these are maybe reads and they are
supposed to be defined in sorted order
so when you off with this file you have
to put it out in sorted order even if
that's expensive to do and maybe not
necessary to some downstream consumers
so I don't mean to criticize so much
whoever came up with these formats I'm
sure there were reasons but I think
everyone in the room has dealt with data
would look at this and say this isn't
how you would design a representation of
whatever this is today so maybe we can
do better and maybe maybe it's worth
doing better likewise if you look at
some of the source code for these
projects this might be from an early
version gatk in Java and you dig in to
some of the the low-level code here
you'll find a lot of mixing of concerns
for example this this high level library
has a parameter to control the number of
file handles that get opened on the host
operating system and I'm sure that
there's a reason for that I'm sure it
mattered for performance of some reason
at some level or at some time
but it just doesn't seem like something
that application-level authors should be
worried about excuse me this is
something we're accustomed to libraries
taking care of for us it's not clear
that someone who's writing genomics
software would even know how to set this
so okay so we've got a we've got us some
legacy code on our hands we got legacy
formats what can we do how can we do
better here well before we get to
solutions let's even expand the problem
a bit this is a pipeline for for one
person this is what we would do to get
from one person's raw sequencing data to
some annotation of the variants in their
genome we don't want to do that for just
one person we'd like to do that for a
lot of people everyone in the room maybe
everyone in a whole country for example
so sure we can paralyze this I mean we
could run a process for your genome on
one machine and your genome on another
machine but that's not necessarily that
efficient for example some of these
stages are very resource intensive and
some are not some are i/o intensive
summer some are not CPU bounds and it's
probably not that efficient to try and
cram each of them onto one machine we
can do it but it's kind of the best we
can do given this current model given
this ad hoc pieced-together pipeline for
genomics that we've got on our hands at
the moment but for example in the UK
there's a project to sequence a hundred
thousand genomes doing the math even
even at given the current cost that's
hundreds of millions of dollars to
sequence 100 100 thousand people's
genomes so there's it seems like it
would be worth it to see if we can do
better and do this more efficiently
because if we can't do a hundred
thousand people we're not going to be
able to get to a million or ten million
so this is why I think people have in in
genomics have started to take seriously
big data big data tools because in a way
there's this whole other audience that's
been building out infrastructure for
large scale cost-effective distributed
computation for years and it's gotten
quite good
so maybe we can we can put the two
together sure
so for example it's not just that we
parallelizing some of these individual
stages might be advantageous it may be
that by combining the results of many
people's pipelines we can produce a
better result than any of them
individually for example it turns out
the variant calling works a lot better
if you can see everyone's genome data
and not just process them individually
likewise the recalibration step also
works better if you can use data
calibration data from all the genomes at
once and not just doing them
individually of course this takes a lot
this adds a lot more complexity and this
is beginning to look like a directed
acyclic graph of jobs that need to be
executed across a bunch of nodes with
the shuffles and so on and I think we've
heard that story before before we get
into computations we might even start by
asking why can't we use more modern data
formats for example why makeup
serialization formats ad hoc why not
leverage formats like meta formats like
Avro and park' that let us define
well-structured formats and then let
them deal with compression let them deal
with the representation and so on so for
example rather than write a bunch of
code to represent the VCF format we
could just write a very similar record
definition Avro for example or parque
and have it generate all the code and
manage all all of the file formats for
us so this has been done for common
formats like BAM & VCF and you can see
that just letting a format deal
specialist format deal with compression
can save a bunch of space out of the box
likewise we've already got answers for
distributing computation and distributed
storage yarn in HDFS and now we have
spark as well to structure these
computations it's a perfect fit for
these types of jobs that need to shuffle
a lot of data need to use results from
one stage in another stage and so on so
maybe it's no surprise that people have
started to build on top of this stack
that it's been evolving outside of
bioinformatics for years with the deve
and HDFS and yarn and spark build on top
of that a new generation of tool
that use all that infrastructure and
just focus on the genomics problems so
maybe it won't surprise you to learn
that there are already open source
projects for this one of the big ones is
atom it's a really an implementation of
a lot of the the pipeline I've mentioned
to you but in terms of standard Big Data
technologies like spark especially so
there's a little bit of Python in here I
think as well so maybe it's sort of
relevant if you're interested go look it
up it's from amp lab the same
organization that brought you spark in
the first place it's a it's an open
source project that anyone can can jump
in and contribute to so the nice thing
is once we have all of the
infrastructure taken care of for taking
care of for us with the right formats
with frameworks like spark and so on the
projects and the code get a lot simpler
they can just focus on the higher level
logic so this is a lots going on here
this is what would have been you know
miles of code before in these other
projects now it's a pretty simple spark
job to do some of the alignments and and
deduplication so so this is something
you can even access in an interactive
shell because it's it's spark based as
well so I think it's a big win
bringing the standard Big Data tools to
the world of genomics and that should
not just drive the cost down and make it
more efficient to run these sequencing
but also let us do more complicated
things maybe push the boundaries of what
we can the the information we can glean
from this genomics data for example this
is something I'm told is hard to do in
general or has been hard to do in the
pipeline's earlier a spatial join where
you actually try and bring together bits
of genetic information based on where
they are in the genome this gets quite
trivial in something like spark that can
easily shuffle and join data efficiently
at scale so that's an example of how we
can not just do things faster but do
things better by leveraging some kind of
modern framework and again because this
is based in spark your Python users out
there can also access it through PI
spark just a quick set of benchmarks to
show that hey this actually does scale
pretty well if you throw four times more
machines at a-- you can roughly speaking
sequence four times as many genomes and
for the in the same amount of time so
the scales pretty well that's good
because Craig Venters new goal is to
sequence a million people's genomes by
2020 we're only about ten percent of the
way there to get there in a
cost-effective way we are going to have
to get better at this so I'm glad these
efforts are underway and before I close
I do want to give credit where credit's
do you if you are interested in these
topics if you think hey I'm a I'm a
Python developer I'm a spark developer
I'm not a genomics person but I'd like
to I'm interested in I want to help out
you're probably the the kind of person
these projects need most these are being
driven by my colleagues Ori at a cloud
era a lot of folks from UC Berkeley
working on the atom project I think if
you walk up to these projects and and
and look for ways to contribute you'll
find you can we do need these projects
need more data engineers than then
biologists at this stage so thank you to
these folks for their work and for the
presentation thank you I want to keep it
short that's all for me I think we might
have a couple minutes for questions as I
said no clever questions about the
biology but if it's about spark I
couldn't might be able to answer it
thank you
so the question is I think format rot we
want this data to be accessible not just
next year but 20 years or 200 years down
the line is Avro a good bet for that
it's probably a better bet than some
ad-hoc made-up format like VCF or BAM so
in that sense yeah it's probably better
to store in some kind of more standard
format than not but I think that's a
really good question
are these are these formats we're going
to be readable and in 20 years I think
the nice thing is formats like Avro are
pretty well defined and self-explanatory
they don't require cryptic custom code
to decode and certainly in their open
source and there and they're openly
defined so probably our best bet
great well thank you very much welcome
to pie data